so again what are these foundations of
so-called
aryanism as we said the debate at this
time and which was had at the council uh
was essentially one about the nature of
the Divine and the nature of the Trinity
particularly what is the relationship
between the Son and the father so the
son as in Jesus Christ and God the
Father what is the nature of their
relationship um and already we should
dispel some common misconceptions about
this um arens did not believe that Jesus
was a Hu just simply a human being uh
similar to what Muslims believe that
Jesus was just a human Prophet or
something like that that was not what
this debate was about